you have an audience that loves
transformers they love the franchise is
there an added pressure when you're here
to really impress them with what you
guys have got well I mean I guess
there's you could look at it as that or
you can I don't know I think I choose to
sort of come here and and share my
excitement with them and get them
excited and honestly I'm more excited
about it than I was before I got here
because the fans have been so incredibly
supportive and it's amazing to sort of
walk into a fan base that's sort of
already sort of already exists but we've
made a film that is kind of a standalone
and and I think that they'll really
enjoy it and find things that they love
from the other Transformers films and
and new things yeah the action of the
Transformers movies are always
next-level from both the robots and of
course the lead human actors so when you
were doing this were there were there a
lot of MOS we had to learn how to do
stunt work how to do white work how to
do all that kind of stuff yeah there was
a lot of yeah I had we had an incredible
stunt coordinator in stunt team stunt
doubles on this movie and I owe a lot to
them cuz there were a lot of times where
I looked at something and I was like I'm
gonna pass on this one
I'm gonna let you do that but yeah there
was a lot of just kind of throwing
myself into it and it's also about being
fearless and the Transformers movie
that's for sure and just really hear you
on the soundtrack as well um the music
in this movie is a very crucial part and
we're in post-production right now so
I've told them if there's an opportunity
that presents itself absolutely well I
hope so hi can we